San Diego Comic Cons Hall H panel for
Marvel with Kevin Feige and the rooster
brothers is only one day away how's it
going everyone it's Warren and tomorrow
we should find out the future of the MCU
this is something that we've been
talking about theorizing about
speculating about waiting for for a
really long time now
even before Avengers endgame came out we
were talking about what is next what is
the future of the MCU hold for us after
avengers endgame all will be revealed
tomorrow but recently something has come
to light that may possibly reveal some
of the movies that could be announced
tomorrow when they announced the phase
four slate
I say possible because of course nothing
will be confirmed until tomorrow but
luckily we don't have to wait long
also the three winners for the 450,000
subscriber giveaway will be announced in
a video later on tonight but today a new
giveaway starts for the 500,000
subscriber mark and this one is going to
be a really big giveaway there will be
multiple winners I'm still giving away
Marvel legend series items such as
Captain America shield iron man's helmet
Infinity Gauntlet and so on but I'll
also be giving away an Xbox or a ps4 the
winner will get to choose which one they
want and a game to go with it so be sure
to subscribe to my channel so you can
enter the giveaway and stay tuned for
more information about the giveaway so
recently some large websites and many
fans have noticed something that could
give us a little bit of insight about
what we can expect as far as movie
announcements tomorrow during hall age
of San Diego Comic Con so I did a video
earlier on this week about the Dark
Avengers The Young Avengers and
ironheart earlier on this week
comicbook.com noticed that if you go to
facebook.com slash Black Widow and
facebook.com slash Marvel's Eternals it
will tell you that the content is not
available right now now this is very
different than a 404 message which
simply states this page does not exist
the message that says this content is
not available right now means that it is
set on private and the public cannot see
it yet so these Facebook pages for Black
Widow and the Eternals two movies that
we know are going to be coming to the
MCU in phase four are just set to
private so this leads many people to
believe that Marvel owns these websites
they have the content on there they're
just not public yet until they announce
them tomorrow at San Diego Comic Cons
Hall H however other
Facebook pages have been discovered as
well a few days ago people have
discovered Facebook pages for the Dark
Avengers of The Young Avengers official
and Marvel's iron heart so these are
three movies that could possibly be
revealed tomorrow at Hall H but in the
meantime many fans have discovered other
websites that give the same message that
the content is not available a lot of
these Facebook pages are for movies that
we know we're going to be coming in
phase four however about half of the
list is movies that we did not expect to
be coming now I have to stress that this
does not officially confirm anything it
could clearly be coincidental or a fan
could have gone and created these
Facebook pages themselves but 17 other
movies have been discovered to have
their own Facebook pages that give the
same message as the Black Widow movie
and the Eternals movies Facebook and a
good majority of them for the most part
make perfect sense so we'll start with
the ones that are kind of expected for
example one of them is facebook.com
slash Loki official now this comes as
really no surprise because Loki has his
own show coming to Disney Plus it would
make sense that Marvel has an official
Loki page for the show that way they can
promote it which of course is something
that they do for all of their TV shows
and movies they promote them on all
forms of social media another one that
makes perfect sense is facebook.com
slash Hulk official right now it's very
unclear what the Hulk's feature is in
the MCU especially since Marvel cannot
do solo Hulk films but we know that
before Avengers endgame Mark Ruffalo and
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios met and they talked about all of
these possibilities for the Hulk and
with a reddit Q&A not too long ago with
Kevin Feige he said that there were a
lot of ideas that him and Mark Ruffalo
talked about some that they have not
done yet that Mark Ruffalo would like to
see so Mark Ruffalo himself is not done
playing the whole foot we'll have to see
what the future holds for him we also
have a facebook calm spider-man official
and a facebook.com slash Deadpool now of
course these make perfect sense Marvel
and Disney now own the rights to use
Deadpool in the MCU and of course we
know there's going to be a spider-man 3
in the MCU as well but here's where
things get pretty interesting we have a
facebook.com slash sinister dot six now
it seems like
have been teased for some time now in
the spider-man films there's been a lot
of talk about them showing up in a
post-credits scene that was deleted for
spider-man far from home that also
introduced Norman Osborn but could the
sinister six get a movie of their own
this is something that not a lot of
people have probably thought about it
makes the most sense to introduce them
in spider-man 3 but who knows perhaps
they could get a solo movie of their own
and then we have a facebook.com slash
Spider Woman official now before we knew
anything about spider-man far from home
there was a lot of talk about Spider
Woman being in the movie now of course
sadly she was not but could we be
getting a Spider Woman movie with the
way Marvel is going with their diversity
and introducing more women superhero
this would make sense that this is on
their agenda and a lot of people would
really enjoy a Spider Woman movie maybe
she is somebody that could show up in
spider-man 3 to help Peter and speaking
of female superheroes in the MC one of
the websites that we have is
facebook.com slash Marvel's she-hulk I
think she hoped is another fan favorite
that many fans would love to have a
movie about and I know everybody would
love to see the Hulk and she-hulk
in the same movie and now that sadly
Natasha is gone I think many people
would like the Hulk to have she-hulk so
with the way Marvel is moving with the
future of the MCU it would not surprise
me one bit if we got a Spider Woman
movie and a she-hulk movie and diving in
that direction a little bit more we have
a facebook.com slash Valkyrie official
now I can see this movie happening
because at the end of Avengers in game
she was made king of Asgard and since
Thor has gone off into space exploring
with the guardians of the galaxy it
would make sense that there would be a
movie about Valkyrie and new Asgard
there would probably be times where
people of Earth called on her and the
Asgardians for help and that could be a
really cool interaction that we see
Valkyrie assisting other members such as
Doctor Strange the Hulk spider-man it
would be really cool to see her interact
with some of these other characters then
we have a facebook.com slash daredevil
official and a facebook.com slash Luke
Cage official now there has been a
recent report that daredevil could
appear in spider-man 3 now this is not
confirmed by any means but there is a
lot of talk about it right now and with
the cancellation of the Netflix series
there could be
chance that they could just simply move
them into MCU films or perhaps they can
make shows of their own and put them on
Disney Plus now we get into a little
more interesting ones we have a
facebook.com slash moon night now moon
night has been rumored to be entering
the MCU for a little bit now in fact it
was reported before Avengers in game
came out that moon night would be in
Avengers in game now obviously this did
not happen but could these reports have
been a little off and perhaps they meant
that moon night would be introduced into
the MCU soon we then have a facebook.com
slash Namor now Namor is expected to
enter the MCU very soon scott derrickson
the director of Doctor Strange and the
upcoming Doctor Strange 2 teased Namor
some time ago
so fans think that Namor could make an
appearance in Doctor Strange 2 also he
could very well be the next villain of
black panther in avengers endgame Ikoyi
mentioned an underwater earthquake off
the coast of africa now
the Russo brothers came out and said
that this is not an Easter Egg for Namor
however they could just be trying to
avoid any type of spoilers at all
remember these are the guys that said
hey the title for Avengers 4 is not
Avengers in game and then of course it
was Avengers in game basically they will
say whatever they need to say to not
spoil anything we know that black
panther 2 is coming up could name or
possibly be the villain for black
panther or could we be getting a name or
solo film build him up and then have him
go fight black panther then we have an
interesting one we have a facebook.com
slash masters of evil this would be very
interesting to see and one thing that is
really interesting about it is Baron
Zemo at one point has a Masters of evil
and Baron Zemo is alive in the MCU he's
not done yet and what's really
interesting is that not too long ago
Roger
Wardell who has been right about
everything that he has leaked on Twitter
so far it said that Baron Zemo would be
returning so could his return mean that
the Masters of evil are coming as well
we then have a facebook.com slash
deviance official and a facebook.com
slash Celestials official these make
perfect sense because we're getting an
eternal movie the Celestials created the
Eternals and the deviance Thanos is
actually an eternal with the deviant
gene so we've already seen a deviant fan
OHS and we know that
there is an eternal movie coming so this
makes perfect sense that we would get a
Celestials movie to talk about them and
a deviance movie to possibly talk about
Fay knows when he was younger and then
of course we have the really big ones we
have facebook.com slash fantastic for
official and facebook.com slash Marvel's
x-men so these are the big ones that
everybody is wondering about when are
they going to be introduced into the MCU
the president of Marvel Studios himself
Kevin Feige said that we would probably
be waiting at least 5 years before the
x-men are introduced into the MCU
however that doesn't mean that they
don't have plans for the x-men and they
could introduce those plans at Hall age
at San Diego comic-con and then of
course right now we have tons of rumors
and reports about Marvel working on a
Fantastic Four movie and we know for a
fact that Peyton Reed who directed
ant-man
and ant-man and the wasp has a script
for a Fantastic Four movie that he
pitched the Fox many years ago but they
weren't interested so now that Marvel
and Disney owned the rights to use the
Fantastic Four it is said that he has
pitched his script to Kevin Feige so
maybe Kevin Feige liked the script maybe
Marvel as talking about a Fantastic Four
movie right now either way it is likely
that Kevin Feige will address the new
characters that they now have in some
way or form we've all been waiting for a
very long time now to see what the next
phase of the MCU is going to be about
and we are finally only one day away
tomorrow everything will be officially
confirmed again take all of this
information with a grain of salt it
could very well mean nothing but
everything will be confirmed tomorrow so
let me know what your predictions are
for what movies could be announced for
phase four tomorrow at San Diego Comic
Cons Hall H again I'll be announcing the
giveaway winners for the 450,000
subscriber giveaway later on tonight
today starts the new giveaway for
500,000 subscribers so be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so you can enter the new
giveaway and be sure to check out my
channel tomorrow for the official
announcement of the future of the MCU as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf